one or two months ago there was a big
headline in the New York Times about IBM
showing Quantum utility and you look at
the paper and what did they do it was
the trotz time evolution of the
two-dimensional transverse field ising
model this is not exactly what the
average person means by utility it's a
far way of being useful for any everyday
applications basically but certainly the
idea of quantum Computing is just based
on stand quantum mechanics which is very
wellc confirmed Theory I think this is
kind of a win-win situation it's like
either they get quantum computers to
work which will be super exciting
because then you can suddenly solve
certain kinds of problems much faster
than we currently can or they don't work
in which case there's something WR with
quantum mechanics which personally I
would even find more interesting